[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited today to tell you
about the shannon nyquist sampling
theorem
which is one of the most important
results in all of information theory
you're going to see it everywhere now
that i'm going to tell you about it
and it's really important especially
when we think about
signal processing control systems
especially compress sensing and sparsity
and kind of the recent
trends in applied mathematics so i'm
going to jump in and i'm going to tell
you all about this shannon nyquist
sampling theorem
which basically tells you if you have
some
signal you're measuring some let's say
it's some signal that's oscillating and
doing something
how fast you have to measure it to
perfectly represent and reconstruct
that signal okay and there's really
interesting connections to code breaking
and other kinds of information theory so
um i i find this a really fascinating
topic
and i hope i hope you do too so
there are two seminal papers uh by
by claude shannon and harry ninequist
nyquist was a little bit earlier in 1928
shannon in 1949 both of them worked at
bell labs
so shannon was an american mathematician
nyquist is a swedish american
mathematician
and both of them developed a lot of
their best work working at bell labs
okay which is kind of this famous think
tank where a lot of great ideas came out
of
um shannon in particular did a lot of
wartime research during world war ii
in encryption and code breaking and
just kind of you can kind of think of
him as america's counterpart of alan
turing and in fact they were
contemporaries
and claude shannon loved turing's work
because it complemented his
his so well so i think that's that's
really interesting uh
as well okay good so
they wrote these two classic papers uh
communication in the presence of noise
and certain topics in telegraph
transmission theory
and there was this idea of kind of how
much
can you compress information if you want
to send it over a long distance
and then be able to decompress it and
get the full high resolution
uh signal kind of out at the end okay so
a really important problem
of their time based on uh on on
communication and signal processing
over long distances how much can you
compress information
and expect to get a faithful
decompression uh kind of
downstream on the other end and of
course we already had lots of
knowledge about this there was already
morse code and
some kind of redundancy built into
communications
in telegraphing but this really put this
on a firm mathematical footing
uh claude shannon in particular uh
is many times oftentimes called the
father or the the father of kind of
information theory and a lot a lot a lot
of what we have in information theory
came from claude shannon so he also took
ideas from thermodynamics entropy
and introduced that into information
theory so he introduced you know
information entropy
when you're sending signals over the
ocean
okay across the atlantic nyquist was
really pivotal in control theory so a
lot of our classical control theory
comes from nyquist
and a lot of things are named after
nyquist so these are two
titans that kind of came together in
this idea
of of sampling uh for the the sampling
theorem
okay good um and i'll just also point
out that that shannon
you know also was very deeply interested
in kind of this theory of secrecy
and the way he said it is that uh kind
of communication
and cryptography are inseparable you
can't study one
without inherently analyzing the other
you can't talk about
communication theory without the theory
of
uh of kind of encoding and coding and
cryptography okay so that's a really
interesting perspective
uh as well and so i want to
kind of just walk you through what they
say the the shannon nyquist sampling
theorem is and then how we can interpret
it
uh today kind of practically so in
in words the sampling theorem says that
a function containing no frequency
higher than
omega measured in hertz is completely
determined by sampling that function
at two omega again measured in hertz
so if you have a function and i'm
actually going to say this
another way i want to flip it also if
you have a function
and you want to perfectly represent that
function you want to perfectly resolve
all of its frequency content perfectly
then you have to sample that function
at twice its highest frequency okay
so i'll say this a couple ways and when
we're used to thinking about functions
uh like an audio signal you can take its
fourier transform
and it's got a power spectrum that tells
you where
in that signal kind of what frequencies
are active in that signal
and if you want to perfectly reconstruct
that signal in fourier
remember we can compress that signal and
send that information
and decompress it if you want to
perfectly represent that information
and you have a highest frequency you
care about you have to sample at
twice that highest frequency okay and so
that establishes what's known now as the
nyquist rate which is two omega measured
in hertz
or alternatively it says if you care
about a frequency omega if that's the
highest frequency you care about
you have to sample at least as fast as a
delta t
of one over two omega in seconds okay
and actually this is really interesting
this is why
if you've ever noticed that your audio
sampling like your mp3
is encoded at 44 kilohertz
that's because humans can hear up to
about 20
kilohertz so you take that highest
frequency humans would ever care about
which is about 22 kilohertz
and you have to double that uh to get
perfect
uh fidelity reconstruction when you uh
when you decompress okay so that's
that's why
audio signals are at 44 kilohertz okay
good uh so i'm gonna just walk you
through kind of pictorially
how this uh this sampling works and then
we'll talk a little bit more about kind
of applications and where you see this
uh every day okay so the idea is that
you might have some signal
um and this is a little hard to draw i'm
gonna do my best let's say you have some
signal
that has a high frequency in it okay
and you
by by kind of common sense if you wanted
to resolve this
uh this frequency you might say that you
need to pick
you know at least two measurements per
period right
to get kind of the high and the low uh
maybe i'll just draw you know to get the
highs and the lows
of this uh of this signal maybe let me
make sure that this
ah that's much better okay so you have
this signal
and to get the highs and the lows of the
signal you would need to measure at
least
two points per period that's kind of
common sense okay
but i'm going to do the thought
experiment what if you down sampled what
if you didn't measure
fast enough okay if you didn't measure
fast enough so let's say
i measure you know less frequently than
i need to so i measure
maybe now and then
now and now i'm i'm not doing a great
job here
but you would essentially get a signal
that could equally well be described
by a lower frequency sine wave so if you
don't sample at this
shannon nyquist sampling rate this two
times uh two times the highest frequency
that you care about then you're
potentially going to miss information
and it could get even worse than that
imagine uh imagine i imagine i measure
at exactly the frequency of the highest
frequency so instead of
at measuring two omega i measure at
omega so i measure just the peak
and the peak and the peak then i have no
information in this signal
as far as i'm concerned the signal might
as well be that straight line
okay and so you can see that there's all
this information that's lost if i don't
measure
at at least the nyquist sampling
frequency of
2 omega so that two omega is critical
because otherwise you'll get this
this phenomenon this is called aliasing
and i'm going to write that up here so
you'll get this
aliasing phenomenon which basically says
that as far as your sampling is
concerned
these curves are aliases of one another
they might as well be the same
person or the same thing as far as this
blue sampling is concerned
so if you sample below the nyquist rate
you're going to get aliasing and you're
going to
lose the high frequency components that
you might care about
now there's a really cool plot that you
can make that kind of shows this idea of
aliasing
and sometimes this is called frequency
folding so if you look at the power
spectral density
versus frequency and remember
uh omega is the frequency i care about
that's where all of my
um all of my frequency content um
actually i'm going to say this a little
differently let's say here omega is what
i'm actually sampling at so i sample at
omega
this is kind of all that i'm able to
sample
but let's say that my my signal has
frequency content up here
at 1.5 omega
okay so if my signal has frequency
content at 1.5 omega but i sample at
omega
i'm actually going to what i what i
measure to my
measurement at this frequency is going
to look like this
so it's going to look like an aliased
version that's folded over
in the frequency domain i'm going to say
this again because this is a little
tricky and a little subtle okay so if
i'm measuring at omega at a frequency
omega now
based on the sam the the shannon nyquist
sampling theorem that says i could only
resolve
frequencies that are at half of that
sampling rate
because i need to sample twice the
highest frequency in my signal so if i
sample at omega
i can only resolve signals that are half
of that rate
but if my actual true data so this is my
true
data over here had a frequency that was
higher than omega
based on this aliasing what's going to
happen is it's going to
look like i measured a system that was
half of that frequency or 0.5 omega this
is going to be
kind of the aliased measurement
so from my measurements at frequency
omega i couldn't tell the difference
between these two
signals and when i fourier transform i'm
going to get this
erroneous low frequency behavior so
that's exactly what i drew here
this high frequency signal was kind of
this signal here
but because i didn't measure it fast
enough at the nyquist rate because i
measured it too slowly
i'm getting this blue erroneous
frequency that looks like it's at a
lower frequency
than it actually is okay so that's this
idea of aliasing you'll see it
everywhere in signal processing um
actually if i wore
a shirt with like a checker pattern you
might get
like a really fine like a dress shirt
with a really fine mesh pattern
then this camera might actually cause
there to be aliasing so as i walk around
from pixel to pixel you'd almost see it
like sparkling that's a weird
camera effect that you get sometimes and
it's because of this idea
of aliasing so you also see this
this is a picture of a curtain i believe
this is
at um heathrow airport i think
and you can see these kind of these kind
of moire patterns
that you see sometimes in optics so this
is kind of an artistic
and artistic rendition of these aliasing
patterns that you get we also saw this
when we looked at the discrete fourier
transform matrix so this is literally a
visualization of the
1024 by 1024 dft matrix
but when i down sampled it when i when i
just
shrunk that image on my computer screen
because
because i used less than 1024x1024
pixels
you actually see some really interesting
aliasing features here i don't know if
you can see it i hope you can
it looks like there are almost four
periodic roles in
x and three periodic roles in y that's
not in the high resolution
dft this is purely because of aliasing
because i'm taking this information
and i'm not measuring it uh finally
enough so that's another application
uh kind of of aliasing okay um
so that's really what i wanted to tell
you about is kind of this really
interesting
uh idea of um
of aliasing and and the shannon nyquist
sampling rate it tells you how fast
you have to measure a signal to get
faithful reconstruction of the frequency
content of that signal
uh and so i'm just gonna i should
probably
write it out to be completely clear so
if you want
omega you need to sample
at two omega it's really simple really
easy to to remember
now what's interesting about this and
i'm gonna kind of close the lecture
on where we're at now now fast forward
you know
70 80 90 years past
shannon and nyquist to today
advances in applied math and
optimization
and statistics are starting to change
how we think about the shannon nyquist
sampling theorem
so technically speaking all of the
results from shannon and nyquist
are for broadband signals so that means
signals that are
full jam-packed with frequency content
from low frequencies all the way up to
that highest frequency that you care
about broadband
dense signals that you've already kind
of compressed
down so think about signals you've
zipped up
that is definitely then the shannon
nyquist sampling theorem
absolutely applies to those dense
broadband signals
you can't beat uh the nyquist sampling
theorem
and have full perfect signal
reconstruction
but if your signal is not broadband or
dense if it is only a couple of
frequencies that are high frequencies
you technically can in fact sometimes
under some conditions beat the
the nyquist sampling frequency on
average and i'm going to talk about this
more
in the context of compressed sensing and
reconstructing audio signals
but for now i'm just going to walk you
through at a very high level what we
expect to see
so here we have a signal f which is the
sum of two sine waves
at 73 hertz and 531 hertz
and so what the shannon nyquist sampling
theorem would say
is that to fully resolve this f i would
have to sample
twice the highest frequency or twice 531
which is
uh 1062 samples per second that's how
fast i'd have to sample
to perfectly reconstruct this signal
okay and here's the power spectrum
here's the signal
now that is technically only true for
broadband signals but this is not a
broadband signal this signal is very
sparse
uh in the frequency domain there's only
two frequency peaks only two tones
making up this function and so you can
get away i'm going to zoom in here
if i measured uniformly
below the shannon nyquist sampling
theorem
or shannon nyquist limit if i if i
uniformly sampled
below the nyquist sampling rate i would
get a terrible signal reconstruction and
i would get this aliasing
but if i measure randomly
but on average at 128 samples per second
so
well below the shannon nyquist sampling
rate but if i do it randomly
not regularly or uniformly then results
in compressed sensing
say that you can actually faithfully
reconstruct the sparse
vector in the fourier domain the sparse
power spectrum and then you can inverse
fourier transform and reconstruct your
full signal
essentially with no aliasing so this is
a really cool result
in the field of compressed sensing i
don't know why this is
comped this is spelled wrong it should
be compressed
sensing or compressive sampling and the
basic idea is that if i sample
randomly in time i can get away with a
much
lower average sampling rate than
predicted by shannon nyquist
if my signal is sparse so i'm going to
tell you a lot more
about this you're going to learn about
this in kind of this lecture series on
compressed sensing
so there's you know there's going to be
more about this for you to dig into
but the basic idea just to recap is that
if you have a signal
f and you care about frequencies up to
frequency
omega then you have to sample at two
omega or else you're going to get
aliasing
and you're going to get this frequency
folding phenomenon
all right thank you